I'm very lucky for my cat oh yeah that
was awesome my cats any animal it's not
just my cats I was just leaving the
house man I saw a biggie outside and the
other blind cabin and I walked up to
Biggie's I put my stuff in the car and I
was letting it warm up you know if you
and I lowered the windows myself
Biggie's at Calphalon neighborhood and I
walked out I said thinking big and he
walked over and just dropped and let me
Pat him this morning Biggie's a big
blonde one of them that famous one was
down the block son makes big E's a bad
[ __ ] biggie was like the
neighborhood pink but then they cut his
balls off and now he's just as mellow
dude this and just this morning I was
walking up and I was thinking on my wife
and the baby and you know you think
about the troubles of the world whatever
the [ __ ] I was thinking about Jesus and
as I was walking the street to pet
biggie just me Patton biggie this
morning just me playing with biggie for
5 minutes because when you scratch big
he's back he goes yeah it was his mouth
but when it comes like these lips like
in like a Japanese movie just that
little rubber is back for five minutes
yeah gave me so much satisfaction oh
yeah and you mentioned it yesterday when
you called back that you know as we
watch the cats at night I have the lady
come in the based on freedom queen of
little boxes and I know my cats I know
they're very social uh-huh so I have you
stop and you like them they like you you
know yeah you stop there and your
freedom you sit there for 10 minutes and
you uh you know tell them whatever that
you love them or whatever the [ __ ] you
tell them and you know you even said it
that you got something out of it
well it was cool and I walked in like
they all they were little looking at me
and I took a couple pictures - those are
so cute but then you told me to go free
- and then I got on the phone because I
didn't like different places for the
bowls and I'm trying to even get it
right but then you're like put a wet can
and even before as soon as I went into
the kitchen what they all came out of
the woodwork and like they were gray
Meow's non-stop laughter which I didn't
I didn't expect and then uh Timmy was
going crazy too and it was cool to watch
because they must been hungry two nights
ago because as soon as I put the food
down they went in there and then I was
like sitting on the couch by myself and
your living room wasn't yes man what am
I doing here but
all came out and start like washing
themselves and CeeCee came over and and
Harry and Amy always come over and it
just it's a I wish I had more time and
for cat I probably could do it but uh I
was I always enjoyed just playing with
the cats do whatever like any time you
you having a [ __ ] up day or whatever
you walk home and whatever was you have
a dog or a cat
you go over you pet your dog you feed
them and then you gotta go do something
for some reason that you feel so bad you
drop to one knee and you just look at
them hug them and play with them and
grab his ear maybe get a ball and throw
for your dog those three minutes you
know they say when you never have all
you live alone people who have dogs and
cats live a little longer you know and I
could guarantee it's those moments